shortly after 9 30 last night the couple
were observed by a member of the public
who recognized them from the media
Appeals
close to a convenience store just around
the corner from where we are today and
observing them calling 999 and following
them to this location where we are now
at point which point the police from
Sussex arrested the couple for child
neglect we're currently in a position
where the baby upon obviously arrest the
baby wasn't present we've moved straight
into an open land search following that
arrest and working on the information
intelligence that we've discussed before
around a couple likely to be staying
over in open land we're using the tent
or outbuildings and as we know the land
and the war the way that they were
walking opens up onto the South Downs
and back towards obviously the locations
that we've previously obviously know
they were sort of towards the New Haven
and Seaford area